in in ottawa ministers
uh good afternoon bon appetit thank you
for joining us for an update on the
ongoing response to the blockades in
downtown ottawa as well as at other
important
border crossings in kutz alberta and in
windsor ontario
while each of these three situations are
unique they are linked by a common
thread
this is no longer about truckers or
vaccines it's about a very small angry
minority who've decided they can stand
in the way of their fellow citizens
whether it's occupying a community or
blocking an international border
and that's not how we do things in
canada
ottawa
is
i will just say that the conversation
that we had with mayor watson yesterday
along with members of his senior staff
and team was very productive
we had an opportunity to unpack um with
a little bit more detail the request for
additional resources
that the ops police chief slowly has
requested of both the federal government
as well as the provincial government and
i would just point out that the mayor
also
sent that letter to premier ford as well
as my counterpart
minister jones with whom i've had a
number of conversations as has minister
blair
i would point out that since the very
beginning the federal government has
been there to provide whatever tools
whatever resources
that we can to support law enforcement
and the ops
we need to see a fast and peaceful
resolution to the convoy and we will
continue to keep open lines of
communication
working with the city working within all
levels of government to get that done
secondly let me say a few words about
the situation in kutz alberta while the
crossing itself remains open there
continues to be significant blockades on
highway 4 both just north of the border
at kutz as well as along at milk river
last night i had a good conversation
with premier kenny
one of the benefits of the police
service agreements is that additional
resources can be requested and
temporarily deployed from across the
country when there is an urgent and
often unforeseen policing requirement
such as the recent protests
i was happy to let premier kenny know at
the time that we would be approving a
request for additional rcmp resources in
the province under article 9.3 of the
police services agreement which of
course will provide the province with
some additional mounties resources on
the ground to ensure that supply chains
continue to move
the provisions of the police service
agreements provide surge capacity to
meet extraordinary policing requirements
that are beyond the normal day-to-day
level of policing requirements
the blockade at kutz has already cost
our economy significantly and we have to
make sure that we end it before it
causes further damage and our commitment
is to work closely uh with uh the
premier as well as his team my
counterpart minister savage
as well as the local rcmp who are
operating as the provincial police of
jurisdiction and of course our cbsa
officers who are doing exceptional work
on the front line
finally
let me talk a little bit about the
situation at the ambassador bridge in
windsor ontario
at the moment the blockade has prevented
traffic from coming into canada while
some traffic is still moving towards the
united states
the cbsa is currently directing trucks
and other commercial traffic to the blue
water bridge in sarnia and sending cars
to the windsor detroit tunnel
traffic at both of those crossings is
moving smoothly and that is encouraging
we've added additional resources at
these two ports of entry as well as at
other key crossings in southern ontario
the ambassador bridge is one of the most
important border crossings in the world
and it carries with it a significant
proportion of all trade between canada
and the united states and speaking
personally and having spent considerable
time in windsor i know just how
important it is to the local community
there to working families to the economy
that we keep those roads open and moving
and i can say that i've already had
direct exchanges with mayor dilkins uh
with my colleague mp kashmir chick as
well as mp brian masay who has reached
out and i look forward to speaking with
him later today and we will continue to
work again very closely uh to see that
this blockade is disengaged so that we
can keep uh the supply chains moving
across the ambassador bridge as well as
the wheels of our economy uh turning i
want to take a moment to thank um all of
the officials at the municipal level in
that community uh as well as our cbsa
officers who are working in conjunction
with windsor police and i do look
forward to
again
staying very much up to date on uh
events in windsor and making sure that
we can see a resolution to this as
quickly as possible
my colleague minister blair thank you
well thank you very much minister
mendocino good afternoon everyone and
thank you for joining us again today um
i'm speaking from my home which is
located in the traditional territory of
the mississauga of the credit today um
as mr mendentino has indicated last
night minister medicine and i met with
mayor watson and officials from the city
of ottawa for what was the first meeting
of the trilateral table but i want to be
very clear from the very outset of this
pandemic
the municipal provincial and federal
authorities have been in your constant
contact i know my colleague and friend
mr menducino has has been reaching out
and has maintained a very close
collaboration uh with his provincial and
municipal counterparts wrote this as has
minister al gabra and other officials in
our government i also want to
acknowledge and commend the
extraordinary and excellent work of our
senior officials within the federal
government working with their partners
provincially and municipally in
responding to to the the protests that
have been taking place in ottawa and the
the disruptions and protests that have
taken place right across the country
as i mentioned yesterday
i also had the opportunity to speak with
minister jones in ontario about the
proposal of establishing this table
because this type of an urgent situation
demands close and continued
collaboration between all levels of
government we all have a role and a
responsibility for keeping
and we all work together in order to
achieve that we are working now to
schedule another meeting for later today
and invitations have been extended to
mayor watts and minister jones and their
respective officials from the beginning
of this pandemic the rcmp our
parliamentary protective services and
other federal partners have remained in
close contact with the ottawa police
service and we continue to act in
coordinating roles between these
agencies
i would also like to acknowledge the
work as i've done of mr of my colleagues
and in particular minister al gabra who
has been meeting with truckers and
representatives from the trucking
industry over the past many days
organizations like the canadian trucking
alliance have made it very clear that
the demonstrations in ottawa do not
represent canadian truckers nor is it
how we uh should engage in meaningful
discourse and advocacy
minister algabra is also working with
his provincial counterparts
to explore what kinds of regulatory
powers could be imposed to end these
unlawful occupations and blockades he
has met with his counterparts in alberta
and transport canada is in regular
contact with the ministry of
transportation in ontario
to the people of ottawa let me
acknowledge we know that the past 12
days have been extremely difficult for
all of you
we hear you and we are doing everything
we can to support the city of ottawa the
ottawa police service and all our
officials in ending this demonstration
safely and as expeditiously as possible
so that things can get back to normal in
our in our city and in our your
communities
and to canadians in every corner of the
country
let me acknowledge how frustrating this
pandemic has been
we have all made sacrifices many
families have lost loved ones throughout
this pandemic and every family has
experienced the deprivations of the of
the restrictions that were by necessity
imposed upon us it's impacted our
businesses in our communities it's
impacted our kids who've been unable to
go to school i know how frustrating it
is for every family that we haven't been
able to engage in our normal activities
to be together to celebrate to travel
internationally and to go about doing
the things that are so important to all
of us we understand and hear your
frustration and we share that
frustration
as the pen as the pres prime minister
said yesterday this pandemic sucks and
it does for everyone
but at the same time let us also
acknowledge the remarkable
sacrifice and resiliency and the work of
our first responders our health care
professionals people who have made this
work and and and i would also take the
opportunity to acknowledge the truckers
you know from the very outset of the
pandemic when we by necessity had to
impose restrictions at our borders we
recognized the important work of of the
truckers in maintaining our supply
chains and they've done extraordinary
work on behalf of all canadians in
making this work the restrictions that
have been imposed
were necessary by the circumstances but
we share everyone's hope
that that as we emerge and as the
science continues to involve evolve that
we will be able to return to a sense of
normalcy but unfortunately the time is
not yet there but we're all working
towards it
let us acknowledge canadians have been
resilient they have risen to the
occasion we have all made sacrifice but
so many canadians have stepped up to
help their neighbors and their
communities and and and we have been
extraordinarily united in our response
to support each other and in in the face
of this pandemic
i believe that we still have a little
work to do and i would ask canadians to
continue to support each other to work
for each other as we work towards the
end of this pandemic and a return to a
more normal life these are the qualities
quite frankly that make us who we are as
a nation they are the values that we all
share and i want to continue to
encourage people we acknowledge the
frustration everyone feels
and and we'll all work together in order
to respectfully bring the country and
canadians through this this incredibly
difficult pandemic
with that minister men mendocino and i
would be very happy to take any
questions that you may have
thank you merci uh it is time for the
questions it will be one question one
follow-up per person uh everyone is on
zoom and the first question goes to
emily bergeron of la prescanadienne
bonjour
that you have with all of this thank you
well if if i may begin
emily and respond and then of course
i'll invite my colleague
as i've said right from the outset even
in preparation for this protest there
has been good communication and
collaboration between all three orders
of government
we also have seen and we've heard very
clearly from from mayor watson of of the
need for his city and for his police
service for additional help and and so
we are
formalizing that that collaborative work
that has been taking place from the
outset by bringing together a regular
meeting uh where these matters can be
raised we're also seeing as well though
that the impact of the protest is
extending even well beyond ottawa and
and is is in fact for example as mr
mendocino indicated um now disruptions
at the the windsor detroit border the
ambassador bridge and in other places
right across the country um so what we
believe it's very important as well that
we continue open lines of communication
with all orders of government so that we
can make sure that we all do uh what is
is necessary to support each other as we
work through these these issues
is
[Music]
on the
um
eventual lifting of restrictions
um bill did you want to start or
if if yeah by all means mark right but
but first of all
the focus of our government has free
right from the outset been on supporting
canadians on helping canadians you know
be safe and and to work through this
pandemic and that's in the focus of all
our discussions and continues to be
um and but but i i want to acknowledge
first of all that we know canadians are
are both frustrated and anxious about
the future
and and i want to assure them that we
with our officials our public health
officials our public safety officials
the entire government is fully seized
with with our work in in order to keep
canadians safe and and to provide them
with a clear roadmap through to the end
in the management of of this pandemic
and
and our commitment as well that we are
always following the evidence the
science the data and the advice that
we're receiving from our public health
officials and we hear very clearly from
all canadians that that they are anxious
to to to see and understand a path
forward and we are absolutely committed
to steering that path on behalf of the
government of canada and the people of
canada and also to communicate that
people though that to people i think we
are all um we all need hope and we all
need um to to acknowledge that that you
know canadians have sacrificed a great
deal um throughout this pandemic and
they are all anxious to to to
to work towards a better future we share
uh that hope and and we're working hard
to achieve it
marco i'd go back to you
um
no papa
[Music]
within caucus
okay next question marika walsh global
good afternoon ministers thanks for
taking our questions
can you
maybe elaborate on what specifically the
federal government is doing to ensure
that the ambassador bridge will be
opened when will it be fully back to
normal and what specifically is the
government doing to ensure
the speedy return to normal business
there
well uh i can take uh a first uh uh
crack at that and then pass on to bill
if he has anything to add but um
first and foremost i would say i'm i'm
very familiar with the community there
and uh know that the road leading to the
ambassador bridge uh huron church uh is
a vital artery uh for goods and services
and it is imperative that um that we
keep traffic uh moving
the specific things that we can do are
again to be sure that our frontline cbsa
officers have all the tools and the
resources that they need and um i can
assure you that
i spoke with president ozowski of the
cbsa earlier today who said that they
were going to be meeting uh with the
windsor police
so that they could be sure that those
efforts are very much in sync
coordinating the strategies on the
ground uh finding ways and concrete
solutions to keep traffic flow moving
and as you heard in my remarks uh we
have been able to to to do that
periodically and intermittently and at
least uh there is some traffic flow
right now uh going in in one direction
and we're obviously looking forward to
to seeing it restored in both directions
at the ambassador bridge the second
thing that i think that we can do uh
specifically is to rely on our cbsa
officials to divert traffic including
goods and services to other ports of
entry and we are doing that both as well
as uh
at the tunnel
at sarnia at the blue water a port of
entry so deploying those types of
strategies uh will be critically
important as we uh manage the blockade
i'll just say that in addition to the
operational work which again is very
much within uh the expertise in the
domain of our officials as well as uh
the police
that
there is a robust engagement of dialogue
that is going on um between uh me and
our colleagues within federal government
and different orders of government i've
had a number of exchanges with mayor
dilkins whom i know very well i've been
in uh good contact with uh mp kasperick
who was one of the mps from the windsor
area and i've already had an exchange
with mp masay and i look forward to
speaking with him later on today by
keeping those lines of communication
open and ensuring that we're getting the
most real-time um information about the
state of affairs on the ground there we
can then relay that to our teams at the
cbsa and really look to uh to
troubleshoot and define practical
solutions so there are a couple of
examples in which i think uh we're
making some progress
thank you for that i'm i'm wondering if
um
from that i should take or we should
take that the government has no line of
sight on when
this will end it seems like you don't
have a timeline if that's incorrect
please let me know and i'm also
wondering you called it in your opening
remarks minister medicine
a very small angry minority but we also
know many canadians
want these restrictions lifted and want
to see an end to some of these
restrictions
so i'm wondering if um by describing
them as a small minority you're you're
allowing yourself off the hook to
actually engage on this discussion
of whether and when
all of these health measures should be
lifted
yeah i mean that's a very
thoughtful and important question and
one that i'm giving a lot of reflection
to and i think everybody is and
you know frankly it allows me an
opportunity to
you know impart to you my thinking about
how important it is to disentangle the
the frustration that we all feel about
wanting to get out of the pandemic
and um
delineating that from
what we are seeing on the streets
outside of parliament hill
and what we are seeing at some of our
official ports of entry
and you know my firm belief is that
those who are taking that frustration
and who are
making like life very difficult uh for
the rest of us those canadians who have
gotten vaccinated and who've made
sacrifices uh is
listening to the dark rangers of our
nature as opposed to the brighter angels
of our nature
and i think
most reasonable and sensible-minded
canadians
do get the distinction that we can all
be exasperated with the pandemic
and want to get back to life as normal
but not allowing that frustration to
overwhelm us
and to then succumb
uh to either breaking the law
or um attributing ourselves to some of
the extreme rhetoric
that we have seen
at the foot of the seat of the
government of canada so i think far from
um you know letting ourselves off the
hook i think we all share
that common sense of
motivation to find uh the fastest and
most effective way out of this pandemic
and
for a number of reasons i think we've
laid that out very transparently that we
believe in government that that's
through vaccinations and to the 90
percent who've gotten vaccinated i think
they agreed to
okay next question ryan tumulty national
post
yeah good morning mister
yesterday
mayor watson
and the chief of police here asked for
1800 more
officers mostly police officers as well
as some civilian staff i'm wondering if
you can give us an update on on that
request have you
figured out how to fill it will you be
able to fill it is it practical
well we had a good discussion with mayor
watson yesterday where we allowed him an
opportunity to
expand a little bit on the letter that
he sent not only to the government of
canada um the prime minister myself and
but in addition to that to premier ford
and to minister sylvia jones i i just
paused to really underline the
significance of
uh who he addressed that letter to
because the province has an incredibly
important role to play
through
my counterpart ensuring that the opp
providing additional resources to the
ops which they have done and it is i
think a moment for me to to thank the
members of the opp as well as the rcmp
uh who have stepped up who have now been
commissioned to enforce the law and to
keep community safety
locally here in ottawa and they're doing
good work there
i think that we have seen good progress
over the last day or so but we need to
see more progress and i think more
quickly and i think that is a sentiment
that we all share as for
um the operationalizing of the details
of of the of the letter
we are going to
continue to have those discussions but
they are properly within the expertise
of the commissioner of the rcmp the
commissioner of the opp and the local
police chief slowly and uh
at a very high line i would just simply
say that the federal government will do
whatever we can to put the resources
that the ops and the city need to get
this convoy um ended as quickly and as
as peacefully as possible and i'll turn
it over to minister blair
very little to add to that but thank you
marco um i i understand that you know
officials require clarity on how those
resources will be utilized um and and
and perhaps greater clarity on on
exactly what what number of of and types
of resources that will be required uh to
assist the city of ottawa and the ops i
i know that there is our officials are
working that within within policing um
but also among our officials those
discussions are
quite appropriately and necessarily
taking place and and at our table our
officials will then provide us with with
advice on on the appropriate deployment
of additional help
to ensure that we provide what is
required by the city of ottawa
yeah i guess just as a follow-up
that was a very vague response to a very
specific question
the mayor and chief asked for 1800 more
officers yesterday
is that practical is that likely he says
that it's absolutely necessary
to end this ongoing occupation of
downtown ottawa so i'm wondering if you
can be more specific about
whether or not
either with the opp or alone by the rcmp
you're going to be able to help with
that request
well let me give you a very concrete
answer ryan
from the outset
the federal government through the rcmp
has been proactive in providing a
tangible concrete support by assigning
275 rcmp officers who are now working
closely with
the ops the opp to enforce community
safety and the work that they are doing
is essential to uh to disengaging the
convoy and to ensuring that there is
an upholding of the law here in ottawa
um yesterday
we met for the literally uh within hours
of having received the letter wasting no
time at all uh to uh make sure that we
understood the exact precision and the
parameters of the request you're quite
right they put a bottom line on the
additional resources that they need and
i know that today
the rcmp commissioner the opp
commissioner are
between themselves determining exactly
how best to respond
to that uh to that request and as soon
as we have an update on that front um we
will provide it to you the other thing i
would say very concretely that we've
covered now with the mayor on a number
of occasions
is that there are additional funds from
which the city can draw to offset uh
some of the uh extraordinary expenses
which have been incurred as a result
of uh the convoy and that is another
concrete solution uh to uh to i think uh
making sure that the resources that uh
the city need are there
and
um i would just point out that
this is important work uh and that the
point of of being able to unpack this
for you
is not only to give you concrete
tangible examples of that work but to
demonstrate uh to you to the people of
ottawa and to all canadians that it's
all hands on deck
that we are working on this day and
night that there are good lines of
communication across all levels of
government and with all levels of law
enforcement to bring about the fastest
and most peaceful resolution to the
convoy
and ryan if i can also
provide a little more precision there
are many precedents where um
surge of police resources have been
required in a jurisdiction in the past
the rcmp the opp and police services
right across ontario have a long history
of working collaboratively and
supportive of each other
where there is a need and that's usually
done under the leadership of both our
public safety minister and the the
the solicitor general in the province of
ontario that's why we're working hard to
support those initiatives but we also
rely
clarity from our law enforcement
officials as to what resources they
require and how they'll be deployed and
used and and so that work is ongoing but
there is many many precedents where
the number of resources that are
required can be provided
when when necessary
we've got about 10 minutes left so let's
try to get as many questions and as
possible next is glenn mcgregor ctv
thank you a question for minister
mendicino throughout these protests
we've seen some groups affiliated with
the uh freedom convoy uh proposed
essentially a coup that would see them
take power over the government
last night uh we heard at a press
conference the organizers of the protest
held
they proposed exactly that forming a
coalition with the opposition parties
and possibly with the governor general
does that in your view
change the nature of this protest
and also does it change
what the response could or should be
from law enforcement
well i'll say at the beginning that i
think again canadians would be troubled
with anyone that associates or
attributes themselves to the extreme
statements that have been made by the
purported leaders of this convoy
that would seek to incite um
the overthrow of the government uh
through violence um that is just simply
inconsistent with the way that our
democracy functions and um i sincerely
hope that um we're all watching very
carefully uh those within our politics
uh who are embarking upon that because
um it is a very troubling path uh one
that i would discourage all of my
colleagues uh to uh
to really uh not embrace um the second
thing that i would say
is that
i think most canadians get that
most canadians understand that um there
is a difference between being tired and
fatigued with the pandemic and then
crossing into some
other universe in which you're trying to
set up a parallel
structure
which is again
just not consistent with the way uh
our proper functioning of government
works
uh and so
um i think we need to be very uh
clear-eyed and sober about that um while
at the same time um being
singularly motivated uh to uh get people
vaccinated so that we can get our our
freedoms but in the meantime
uh just to be very very uh sure that um
those who are
uh who are not following the law are
held accountable
with respect to the
discussions with the city of ottawa
about additional rcmp resources can you
give a little more detail on exactly who
those rcmp members might be
are these just regular frontline rcmp or
are they specialized in any way we talk
about tactical squads
if if they if you agree to that request
who who might we see on the streets of
ottawa in rcmp uniforms
well you know in terms of the uh details
and and exactly who is being assigned
and from what um rcmp branch i would
direct you to directly to the rcmp just
because they
as you know glenn and you know you've
been covering this now for some time
are responsible for operations
our job
my job minister blair job is to ensure
that the rcmp have all the tools all of
the resources that they need in
responding to the requests that have
been submitted to them from the ops and
the city and again we'll continue to
work closely with them as well as mayor
watson and his team and our counterparts
in the in the province to see the most
peaceful and uh quick resolution to the
convoy
okay next question travis danraj cbc
thanks very much elizabeth question for
minister blair uh minister i think
everybody knows that you were the former
chief police in toronto uh i covered you
often um i i'm just wondering
you know the the protesters that were
coming
last weekend uh even before last weekend
said that they were going to stay
like there was there are indications
that they were going to stay put
and in a letter uh that was sent to the
federal government and to the province
yesterday the the mayor said that the
the ottawa police have not been able to
contain what he called an insurrection
i am just wondering
if you think the ottawa police
failed here uh when it comes to
containing us and now we're in today 12
where the nation's capital is in a state
of emergency
well thanks uh travis and it's and it's
good to see you again and i remember
those many times that you were asking me
similar questions that you're now asking
the chief in ottawa i'm very mindful
however that like under no circumstances
is it ever appropriate for an elected
official to be giving um direction and
i'm not the minister that would be that
is responsible for policing in ontario
and so um that's not a question i'm it's
not for me to to pass comment or
judgment on on that but it is our
responsibility to make sure that that
the the municipality of of ottawa has
the resources that it requires that's
why we're working so closely together
and working with the province of ontario
um because we we all share a common
purpose of of of serving the people of
of all of our communities this has been
hugely disruptive to to the people of
ottawa you know on the one hand i i
think you know we all respect that are
in in our charter people have the right
to lawful peaceful protest but we've
also seen many examples here where where
where that protest has has gone well
beyond lawful and peaceful and in fact
is infringing on the rights of other
canadians um even you know the the the
activities that are now taking place at
the ambassador bridge in windsor that's
a vital
artery of of supply and services uh for
the province of ontario it's it's
absolutely essential to our economy and
and you know it's one thing to to to
protest but when that protest um
infringes upon and and impacts so
significantly the the the people of
ontario i i think it it does require
an appropriate response that's why we
have the laws that we have in this
country and it's why we we give the
authority of the police and and the
support and resources to the police to
do the important job of keeping us safe
and upholding the rule of law
travis if i could i'll just quickly add
to minister blair's answer um
that i do think that there will be an
opportunity we hope in the very near
future to reflect on the way the
situation has unfolded uh in ottawa
um it's been exceedingly difficult for
people who live here and i don't think
we can gloss over that
um and it's beyond just um inconvenience
uh and it's beyond just disruption um
people have been victimized
uh repeatedly daily hourly they're tired
they're at their rope's end and this is
not the way that uh we treat one another
as we try to get ourselves out of the
pandemic so i do think um we need to
have the conversation about uh ensuring
that this kind of situation never
happens again in our nation's capital
and just to pick up on that minister
mendocino and mr blair maybe you can
weigh in as well would you be supportive
do you think a public inquiry
uh
should happen to to look into how we got
to this point i mean there's millions of
taxpayer dollars that are being spent
now on law enforcement so would you be
in support of a public inquiry in terms
of uh how the city of ottawa is at this
point now
travis i i would sort of make the point
that we're kind of embarking upon that
in real time by coming out here and
taking questions from you and your
colleagues every day but i think the
longer term conversation does need to be
had that we do need to learn some
lessons about um the way that we uh
prepare ourselves and are ready uh to
respond to uh this kind of of a
demonstration the kinds of uh blockades
that we've seen uh here in ottawa and
also to have that conversation um relate
to the parliamentary precinct um from uh
you know the perspective of
both
me and minister blair and i think all of
our colleagues who work on the hill uh
and the the the concern that we have uh
so that uh both transiting to and from
um parliament everyone feels safe um you
know we need to have that conversation
as well but i'll turn it over to
minister blair to add yeah and not much
more to say except
right now we're focused on on bringing
this to a piece of resolution and and
and i think that's the important work
that needs to happen in the in in the
aftermath of any such event it's always
important that lessons be learned and
applied and as exactly as mr menducino
said we've been reflecting throughout
this pandemic on on ways you know
some of the challenges of the
environment and how it's being managed
and and ways in which we can do better
and so we'll apply those lessons and and
and
but right now
quite necessarily our focus is on
bringing this to a peaceful resolution
for the people of ottawa and for all
canadians who are being affected
impacted by this
okay if we can squeeze in one last
question uh palik mangat uh manga from
uh politics today
hi can you hear me okay yep yep
hi mister thanks for taking our
questions um just on a different note
and i know that you were asked about
this in french uh but i just like to get
your reaction to mr lightbound coming
out today and voicing his uh i believe
the word he uses discomfort around some
of the debates and divisive politics and
tone that the party has taken dating
back to the um
the election he's saying that there are
others within caucus who feel similarly
uh i just like to see whether or not you
share some of his concerns do you think
that there are other mps within caucus
who could also be having these worries
and what does that mean
i guess by way of confidence within
caucus around the government's handling
of the endemic
marco i'll i'll i'll jump in first of
all i've been a member of of the liberal
caucus now for over six years and
and and and i believe that we are a
caucus that that listens to each other
and that there's plenty of opportunity
for for a wide variety of opinion within
that caucus i think
more i reflect on you know the broader
anxiety and frustration that canadians
are feeling with respect to this
pandemic it's been very difficult for
everyone um and and i would just simply
respond that that we have all been
working full out in first of all to keep
canadians safe and to take the steps
that that our health officials have
advised and that we believe were the
right thing to do in order to to ensure
people were safe i think one of the one
one of what is clear is that vaccination
is is is a an incredibly important part
of keeping canadians safe and and and
acknowledge that the overwhelming
majority of canadians close to 90
percent have have now gone out and
become fully vaccinated we're going to
continue to work on those things and at
the same time in we recognize that as we
work through this pandemic and the
situation continues to evolve
we we are also we share all canadians
hope um that that we will be able to to
return to some some greater sense of
normalcy everyone is anxious to see that
happen we're anxious to see it happen
too and we're all working tirelessly to
make it happen and and part of that is
making sure that we provide you know
with with our health officials and and
others the supports they need access to
vaccinations and take the measures that
that will keep us safe and at the same
time when the need for those measures
begins to abate we're always evaluating
the necessity because we recognize the
impact that even our our most important
measures can have on all canadians
oh yeah i'm sorry just a follow-up um i
believe this is probably from mr mancino
one of the things that mr leibn
highlighted is is the need to pivot and
start thinking more longer term and i do
take your point and you and i know that
you said this on monday as well um that
when it comes to the protests and the
situations that have been going on here
um
you're saying that there's a need to
focus on the short-term goal of
operation so on the ground with law
enforcement but i guess my question is
just given now that we have
uh one of your one of your colleagues
now publicly striking a similar message
does that place
a sense of urgency
on focusing on these longer-term
reflections sooner rather than later and
by extension will there be some
formalization of these talks
i think we may have lost minister
mendocino uh minister blair do would you
want to respond to that
yeah if if if i may and i'm sorry that
that was that technically we seem to
have lost minister mendocino and i know
he
he would have
wanted to respond
um to your question you know
in in every circumstance we have to deal
with the immediate the immediate impact
of of the protests that are taking place
in ottawa the the
the
blockades that are are are you know uh
occasionally popping up in alberta and
and and and now in windsor and in other
places are are urgent matters that need
to be dealt with in an urgent way and at
the same time i just want to assure
everyone including
all canadians that that that we are also
you know looking very carefully at at
at the future and how we can bring the
country
um through this pandemic and and beyond
you know the the circumstances we find
ourselves in now there is a long-term
view and and all of our officials are
seized with that responsibility we
recognize that and as we have from the
very beginning we've heard from
canadians who were concerned about
restrictions on international travel
their ability to see family and friends
um you know this the the impact on on
that some of our provinces have
restrictions that they've put in place
with respect to kids going to school the
impact on the business community from
the very beginning
we knew
we needed to be there for canadians to
provide the supports financial supports
and other supports in in order to to
support canadians but also to take the
steps that were necessary to keep them
safe we we have seen that that we have
made some progress in in in this
pandemic we've learned some lessons um
the data you know our public health
officials work relentlessly to gather
data and to learn from the experience of
other jurisdictions and apply it here
and and we are also hopeful that as we
work through this some of the
restrictions that have been absolutely
critical and necessary and successful in
keeping canadians safe
that we may have the opportunity to
begin to ease those restrictions at the
appropriate time based on the evidence
based on the advice that we receive from
our health officials we're always seized
by that um and and we acknowledge the
frustration but then i'll go back to the
matter of urgency
when when people express that
frustration and everybody's entitled to
to to the to freedom of expression but
when they do it in such a way it impacts
on on the lives and the safety on the
health of other canadians
you know the threats of of violence the
intimidation the the symbols of hatred
and and intolerance that have been on
display even quite frankly some of the
delusional um
modifications of people who think that
that they are perhaps more fit to take
over the government all of all of those
things need unfortunately to be dealt
with in the immediate but we are we'll
never take our eye off the best interest
of canadians we are all uh focused and
and and and seized with that
responsibility and we're working through
it
thank you very much this ends this press
conference
thank you
you